in the speedster region of doom the
Legion of Doom oh I'm not calling them
that January 24 we're in sort of a time
clock here
Tuesday's the Legion have nothing they
have rip will be legendary
who do we kill first these guys are good
DC's legends of tomorrow all new
episodes return on a new night Tuesday
January 24th on the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie everybody bow
down to the new god of the DC Universe
the reverse-flash with the spear of
destiny so I'll explain what's going on
there's a bunch of other footage in here
for the next episode to the flash ring
giveaway is also still going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be
sure to click that Bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything during the
break so let's address the rip hunter
footage in this first because the whole
thing is about the Legion taking control
of rip hunter there's really only one
reason why they would need to do that if
they needed him to get one step closer
to finding the spear of destiny
they assembled the artifact so they have
sort of like a star chart map but that
might not lead them directly to the
spear of destiny that might just be like
the next step on their path to obtaining
it so the only reason for them to really
go after rip hunter is if rip hunter
knows where it is or has the information
that will get them one step closer the
episode that most of this footage is
from is called Raiders of the Lost art
as in Raiders of the Lost Ark so that
just implies that there's a piece of
artwork somewhere in history that tells
them where to find the spear of destiny
so the Legion needs to find the artwork
they need to get rip hunter to find out
where that is but the post credits scene
from the last episode was rip hunter in
this like 70s getup with giant sideburns
directing this movie based on the plot
of legends of tomorrow
and we try to get this right people I
don't want to be here all night
[Music]
am I talking to myself today
so it seems like rip hunter knew that
this was all going to happen the legion
was going to come after him so as a
defense mechanism he wiped his mind to a
certain extent so part of the comedy of
this is them just running into him hey
rip we haven't seen you in a while in
him just being like I have absolutely no
idea what's going on and I'm speaking
with an American accent so we don't
really know how many episodes rip is
going to be in in the back half of the
season or how he's going to figure into
this spear of destiny plot because that
is the key to the reverse-flash gaining
the powers of God in the ability to
rewrite reality and that's what this is
all about this whole season is about the
reverse-flash getting the spear of
destiny so that he can erase Barry Allen
from existence without erasing himself
it's the only way around the problem
that he can find the future flash
message that they referenced on legends
will probably figure into this is well
as thus avatar plot to so they're really
tying these shows together in a really
big way even though their main plot seem
like there's so even if you haven't read
the comics you don't know a lot about
eobard thawne the reason he can't kill
Barry Allen is because the speed force
comes from Barry Allen he generates it
when he runs he's like the source of the
Speed Force in all of the multiverse on
all the planets in all of the universes
so if the reverse flash kills Barry
Allen
it means the Speed Force won't come into
existence so if the reverse flash kills
Barry Allen it effectively kills his own
future so he needs to find a way to
erase Barry Allen without erasing the
things that come with Barry Allen namely
the Speed Force the only way to do that
is to rewrite reality in the only way to
do that is to gain the powers of a god
via the spear of destiny what is the
most effective way to use this
we had to talk about this wielding the
spear there are a lot of different ways
they could do this on the TV show but
the most amazing way for him to do that
would be to just run Barry through with
the spear like literally impaled him on
the spear of destiny
so in gaining the powers of the spear
the reverse-flash gains the power to
rewrite reality becomes a God in his own
right which is funny because we have a
God of speed on the flash right now
Savitt are but remember he only calls
himself a god that was such a great
quote the way they wrote it you don't
need something to absolutely be true you
just need to get enough people to
believe it's true to make it true but
what we're talking about reverse flash
spear of destiny
that's literal God like you actually
have the powers of God so what about the
rest of the Legion of Doom in the rest
of this footage there's like a couple
other things that you may have spotted
in here one is vixen in bed with citizen
steel which is weird because she had a
thing going on with his grandfather
commander steel so this just got real
weird real fast plus she also has all
that chemistry with heatwave no idea
where that's going and then there are
the colonial soldiers where we also saw
rip hunter pop up so big twist might be
that there are different aspects of rip
hunter splintered across time and they
have to combine them all to get back the
regular rip hunter like if you remember
Marvel's time runs out storylines that
led into Secret Wars molecule man is
somebody that exists in multiple
realities at the same time so they might
have done that same thing with rip
hunter where you have many different
aspects of rip hunter just splintered
across time as a defense mechanism for
preventing the reverse-flash from
getting the spear of destiny so that
might be what they're doing in the back
half like they'll have to go around and
collect all these rip hunters so the
other big thing there's like so much
stuff that's happening with the legends
of tomorrow they're moving it to Tuesday
nights after the flash so like the flash
is on at 8:00 p.m. on Tuesday nights at
least in the United States right after
that will be legends of tomorrow so I
don't know if that's going to be the
same thing in other countries you'll
have to check your listings this
schedule change might just be for North
America so just be sure to check your TV
schedules for that last week in January
its January 24th when it's coming back
so that's also the day that the flash is
coming back to so it'll be flash then
legends of tomorrow and then arrow is
still on Wednesdays at the same time so
I'm gonna have to figure out what the
new video schedule is gonna be but we
have a couple weeks to figure it out so
it's not a big deal
I'll remind everyone about the change
when we get a little bit closer but
again it's not coming for at least
another four or five weeks so it's not a
huge deal right now
but let me know in the comments what do
you think is gonna happen when the
reverse-flash inevitably gets his hands
on the spear of destiny something is
gonna have to happen to get it out of
his hands because you know just like fan
OHS assembling the Infinity Gauntlet in
Avengers infinity war you want to see
that moment where the villain stands
triumphant becomes a god in his own
right and then the real fun after that
is watching how the heroes fix that in
whether or not is going to involve other
versions of the flash or it's just gonna
be the legends in what the hell is Sara
gonna do when she finds out that Laurel
is back seemingly somebody who doesn't
know what's been happening for the last
couple of months the way they set it up
in the arrow trailer is that she doesn't
know anything after she died last season
so it's almost like the version we're
getting is the version that died she's
just coming back but because she's been
in the ground for a couple months she
hasn't been around for all this
craziness
so because it's the holiday weekend
there's gonna be a whole bunch more
comic book stuff dropping still keeping
her eyes peeled for a Justice League
trailer if there are any bonus videos
you guys want specifically this weekend
just let me know in the comments but I'm
gonna be doing some best of Christmas
themed comic book videos from Marvel and
DC like spider-man saves Christmas the
flash saves Christmas there's a whole
bunch of really awesome holiday comic
book stories while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for the
flash trailer for the next episode and
you can click here for the arrow trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight